let's move on to the other big thing
that the administration did now college
loans this it's interesting i know
there's people who have college loans
there are other people in america the
vast majority of americans didn't go to
college and they don't have college
loans so they're a little pissed about
this
they're like you know there are plumbers
out there saying well why don't you pay
off my truck
instead because that's what
my money went to my life went to it's
amazing to me when i read in the paper
today how many democrats are divided
about this they're not completely behind
this idea that joe biden is paying off
people's student loans
so where are you on that one
i think you know during the presidential
i was the one that said rich kids we
shouldn't be paying for their college
you just can't staple a diploma for free
under everyone's chair part of that is i
think we need to focus on
apprenticeships and filling the hard to
fill jobs that being said bill this is
more targeted than a bunch of the
proposals that were out there um and 87
percent of the money goes to people uh
that are making less than 75 000 a year
you've got
well it will help nurses it helps nurses
it helps teachers it helps electricians
a bunch of people have community college
loans that being said if i could wave a
magic wand and do what i want to do i
would have actually tied it to the hard
to fill jobs we have 10 million job
openings right now in our country 2
million of our in health care assisted
living so if people will go into those
jobs instead of being like hedge fund
managers
then we could actually put the
loan repayment help
and have it connected to people going
into the jobs that we need to fill i
think that would be a way you can do it
but i do think it's important for people
to understand that this is a targeted
program that he put out 50 years ago 70
of good jobs
required a high school diploma now they
say 70
require a college degree so i know this
is like supposed to address income
inequality but it kind of does the
reverse because it's the people who have
college degrees
yeah but there are also
parents of those kids who don't have
college degrees who want their kids to
be able to go to college so that they
can have a better life than they did and
we have to address the the cost of going
to college i mean i'm an old man but
when i went to college you know at ucla
it cost me 242 dollars to go to school
for a whole year now it's crazy how much
you have to pay and it's unfortunate and
it does target the the the kids that are
most of uh you know most in need but i
keep saying on this show no one's
listening but i keep saying well you're
it's your show i know no no i'm just
saying i'm just saying nobody you know
eventually they follow my lead but it
takes years a decade it takes years
someone else to claim it anyway but i
keep saying it's not about affordability
uh yes college is unaffordable it's
about making college more unnecessary
it's a giant scam
it's a consumer product
that they're selling you
as a golden ticket to be in the upper
middle class but they're not really
getting any education did you go to
college of course of course because
of your own show would you have your own
show with maybe you would i don't know
uh yes i would exactly yeah yeah no i i
no i mean actually i mean yeah but you
wouldn't qualify for the loan repayment
income yeah i'm just saying most jobs
they do not really require it's a scam
and i've you talked about nurses i've
talked to so many nurses my mother was a
nurse i still know many nurses that were
friends okay
administrators teachers they all have
this complaint that at a certain point
they need more education
to like advance in their career when
really they know exactly what they're
doing they don't it's just a way to make
you go back to school and i feel like
education is to democrats what tax cuts
are to republicans they think it solves
everything
well it's not just upper education
you're also talking about k-12 and
that's something that democrats have
cared about forever and you see uh
republicans moving away from public
education that to me is where the big
the money should be going and yes there
are people who should go to college if
you want to be a doctor you want to be a
lawyer you want to do something that you
know you want to be in the space
industry you have to go to college there
are other jobs that you don't need
college for
choice i think you and i have shared
this view we're not going to have a
shortage of sports marketing degrees
here we're going to have a shortage of
plumbers electricians we have a shortage
of nurses technology workers and some of
those jobs require high education some
of them require apprenticeships and we
just got to meet people where they are
and that's why i'd like to tie it to the
jobs that we need to fill
you